[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rodney harrison should be in the hall of
fame he was a part of uh two super bowl
champion teams with the patriots he of
course an analyst on football night in
america and uh coverage begins a special
on-site edition of football night
america at 7 eastern
rodney how are you buddy
what's up dan how are you man
what do you think happens in this game
as far as like just overall yeah
yeah i mean we've all week i've talked
about the the dynamic between coach
belichick and tom brady we haven't
really even talked about the game
but i think excuse me i think it's going
to come down to the patriots defensively
you know obviously putting pressure
making tom uncomfortable inside the
pocket and being very physical at the
line of scrimmage with the line with the
wide receivers and the tight ends i
think you know if if you think about
coach belichick for 20 years he's been
sitting back
and watching tom brady eat up his own
defenses for 20 years you know and i
think that'll be
one of the craziest defensive plans to
go out there and just slowly sit back
and zone coverage i think you got to
play aggressive i think you got to get
physical and you got to challenge these
guys take away that short passing game
and force tom brady to beat you down the
field okay do the patriots have the
personnel to do what you're suggesting
yeah they have the personnel to do it
they have a lot of veteran players um
guys in the secondary guys up front this
is a veteran laden defense and we saw
what they did against a rookie
quarterback uh zach wilson but this is a
totally different guy and tom brady but
pressure is the key you get pressure up
front and i i anticipate some five-man
pressures but the pressure is key and
bill belichick knows that then
can you throw it can belichick throw
something at tom that tom would not be
prepared for or had not seen before
absolutely and tom's seen everything but
you still have to understand when tom
comes to the line of scrimmage he
doesn't know what the defense going to
do he doesn't know if belichick is going
to bring two corners if he's going to
bring two inside linebackers yeah he's
seen a lot but at the same time you
still have to process all that
information as a quarterback and the
patriots do a great job of disguising
moving around showing that you know
maybe the middle linebacker blitz oh
maybe the nickel blitzes so they they do
a good job of disguising what they do
and um you better believe coach
belichick he's gonna come after brady
do you think bill belichick cares about
all of this drama can he treat this as
just another game
he always has i mean when we won the
super bowl when we were 12-0 and 13-0
and 14-0 he is the master at making you
focus one day at a time one game at a
time and you know nobody is better
suited for the situation than coach
belichick and what he would tell those
guys on monday the first thing he would
walk in in the meeting room then and say
the circus is in town you know he said
guys don't answer any questions for
anyone else we're trying to win a
football game all the other brady stuff
you're going to hear about that all week
but at the end of the day
answer for yourself and take care of
your business and do your job that's
what he addresses the team so now the
team is already programmed during the
week to stay solely focused on the game
and not all the bs that comes with it
but tom coming back with all the emotion
of those fans and he's beloved there
they don't begrudge him that he left new
england
how do you think tom processes something
like this because it it's personal for
him
as opposed to coach might be able to
separate this and just say let's i got a
football game
tom's a pro and all week he's given
nothing but props and
you know i mean he's talking about how
much he respect coach belichick how much
belichick was a mentor for him so i
don't think it's going to be like super
hard for him to separate i think he's
done a good job all week as he gets to
the game and gets closer to the game
you'll have that normal anxiety and
anxiousness that you have before you
play a game but at the end of the day
time is a time is a goon time time is a
thug he wants to rip the patriots face
off
you know off their off off their head he
just he's one of those guys he wants to
win if he can win by three four or five
touchdowns that's exactly what he's
going to do
how would you go against brady if you
let's say you're playing in that patriot
secondary what would you be trying to do
or if you were advi if coach belichick
reached out and said rodney come on in
and talk to the dbs what would you tell
them
i tell them you got to be you got to be
aggressive like you know one thing about
tom is you can't go with his first look
when he's looking over here and he's
dropping back five to seven yards you
can't go over there you have to stay
disciplined in your area in your zone
and make sure you take care of your
business because that first look is just
to get you to move and he's always
coming back this other way and and just
you know stay patient he's gonna make
some great plays you know stay patient
continue to compete and fight and that's
all you can do
how good is that tampa offense in your
opinion
i think when antonio brown back
it just gives tom that level of
confidence godwin mike evans um i think
it's really good especially if you get a
healthy grunt bronch is kind of that x
factor he's not going to put up big
numbers but he's still a pain in the
butt in a red zone straight down the
middle and he's a guy that can get you
those keep third down conversions so
gronk is still a problem even though
he's not 100
what do you make of mac jones so far
i think this is a young man that um he
has what you want mentally i think he
has um
i think he's a he's going to be a really
good young player he's starting to
really process information and he said
it himself he said he has to do a better
job of being patient going through his
reads but also believe that josh
mcdaniels has to do a better job of
you know allowing him to throw the ball
down the field taking shots down the
field one thing about tampa bay's
defense they struggle in the back end
the deep part of the field antoine
winfield and those guys so if i'm coach
um if i'm coach josh mcdaniels take some
shots down the field because now what
people are doing is defenses are
starting to blitz mack jones and they're
starting to come after him four or five
man pressures just like the saints did
and if he can't prove that he can handle
that blitz they're gonna show it week in
and week out now he has to do it with
todd bowles and all the exotic that
stuff that he shows so if if he can
handle the blitz that's going to be the
key for the patriots because todd's
going to show him 10 15 different looks
he's rodney harrison nbc football night
america analyst and won two super bowls
with the patriots you were there when
randy moss was there right
yes sir is there a better wide receiver
than randy moss in the history of the
game
um one guy that i've gone against
consistently
and i played with randy and randy was
incredible but one guy is just jerry
rice
and it wasn't as exciting as randy moss
but it was very consistent and he was a
threat and he caught everything and his
routes were immaculate and he worked his
butt off every single route so if
there's a guy that i was afraid of with
the point when when we played against
the raiders and randy moss we kept three
guys on randy moss basically
we were not giving up the big play but
jerry rice is one of those guys he's a
grinder he'll come across the middle
slants he'll take a slant and even
though he was a 4-5-4-6
you know he'll make a move beat the
safety and sprint to the end zone jerry
rice was a royal pain in the butt i saw
him last week when i was in san
francisco he still looks great but i
would have to say jerry rice and you
faced him he was 34 years of age when he
was with the raiders
well i faced him also when he was with
the 49ers because when i played with the
chargers we used to always have that
inner squad um scrimmage so i got a
chance to see him terrell owens i got a
chance to see steve young up close and
personal like when they were in their
primes and it was awesome to see
terrell owens is right there why is why
does t.o not get the credit maybe that
he deserves or feels like um i guess
personality demeanor but as far as when
he got on the football field
can you can you argue with what he did
how he produced
you can't and it was an absolute shame
and t.i we haven't you know we've had
some words and we don't get along we
don't go out and have cocktails or
anything like that but i've always said
that this guy should have been a first
ballot hall of famer no question about
it he was an absolute stud um just the
threat of terrell owens caused what the
pressure that he puts on a defense and
the things that he could do yeah it was
personality a lot of guys didn't a lot
of people or voters didn't appreciate
the way he he acted and the way he
carried himself but at the end of the
day you have to go by what this man
accomplished on the field and what he
accomplished on the field you can't deny
he was one of the greatest wide
receivers ever i don't care what stats
say this dude was an absolute monster on
the football field and um i just love
the way he played play really motivated
played tough and with a sense of urgency
how concerned would you be if you're a
steeler fan
what you've witnessed so far with ben
roethlisberger
oh i would be highly concerned because
at the end of the day it starts with the
offensive line the offensive line isn't
great they can't run the football they
have the perfect running back for their
system you got naji harris a guy that's
big fast elusive can catch the ball out
of the backfield yet you can't run the
ball because you don't have an offensive
line then you have ben he looks like
he's 90 years old he looks like he's you
playing
quarterback playing quarterback for the
pitch
so i am definitely concerned about um
the pittsburgh steelers definitely are
you all in on matthew stafford in the
rams
you talk about like going to the super
bowl and all that stuff yeah
i'm not all in it's it's a month in the
season you know but i'm i'm i'm i'm
excited about the rams i'm excited for
matthew stafford to go to to have to
stay in a program where you've lost the
majority of your career and now going
somewhere where it's a lot more positive
than you got athletes you got a good
defense you got other guys that you can
depend on and you have hope ain't
nothing like that man i'm telling you
matthew stafford feels like he's a
rookie again he loves him but he might
play another 10 years
let's say you're in your prime
maybe maybe the back end of your prime
you're like richard sherman
bill belichick reaches out
tom brady reaches out
who are you signing with
tom brady absolutely because you have
the chance to win you gotta understand
richards made his money like he doesn't
have to go and make extra four or five
million he's playing because he wants to
play but yeah tom brady calls me up how
do you say no to tom brady especially
when you know
what level of um defense that they have
when they're healthy and to bring all
that knowledge that experience in there
and to be able to talk to the young
players and show them and show them
different things hey man that's an easy
choice plus let me tell you this dan
you're playing on natural grass and
you're playing 70 degree weather every
time every day you wake up it's natural
grass in 70 degree weather how could you
beat it
do you ever witness brady chugging beers
i don't think i've ever seen brady take
a alcoholic drink until that when i saw
him drunk coming off the boat
remember that super bowl parade or
whatever
oh yeah
oh yeah i've never i've never seen him
take a drink but i don't hang out with
tom brady like we don't go to bars i
don't go to bars so i wouldn't know but
did you ever hang out with brady
not like night life i mean having dinner
or
[Music]
was it just we talked you know we when
we talked and we've had dinner at you
know in lunch at the stadium and
breakfast and we would talk about family
and our goals and stuff like that i mean
he's a very interesting guy and let me
just say this dan about brady i'm so
happy for him
people didn't get a chance to see his
personality now that you social media
he's gone to a new spot um you know all
the commercials now we get a chance to
really see who tom brady is and that
sarcasm that humor the good looks just
all the different things that come with
tommy yes he is a weasel he is a weasel
you better believe that but at the end
of the day you know i'm just happy that
he's at a really good place
good to see you rod i hope you're well
family's good and uh have fun uh on uh
sunday night
same same with you dan you look good man
good to talk to you thank you brother
that's rodney harrison football night in
america won two super bowls